لن يحدث بكبسه زر او بقطع شريط احمر لكن
بدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد او عدمه بات
موضع تساؤلات مع ظهور الدلائل المفترضه اي
دخول فصل الربيع وجفاف الاراضي الموحده
التي عرقلت سابقا حركه المركبه الثقيله
اوكرانيا مستعده لشن الهجوم المضاد ويمكن
ان يبدا غدا او بعد اسبوع
ورغم غياب اي تحركات دراماتيكيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه حتى اللحظه الا ان الهجوم
المضاد قد يكون جاريا بالفعل بهدوء في ظل
عمليه متواصله على طول حدود ممتده لالف
التدمير المكثف للوجيسيات العدو روسيا هو
ايضا هجوم مضاد
اختراقات الحدود الروسيه تكررت مؤخرا مع
استهداف صواريخ اوكرانيه لمناطق مختلفه في
بيلجروت جنوب روسيا بينها شبه القوات
الاوكرانيه استغلت كذلك وجود ادنى مستويات
الرطوبه التربه في زابوريجيا وخيرسون
فمحاولتها مستمره لاسترجاع مدينه ميليتوبل
وذلك سعيا منها لكسر الجسر البري بين
روسيا وشبه جزيره القرم ما يؤدي الى قطع
خطوط الامداد اللوجستيه الحيويه الحمله
الاوكرانيه تدفع كذلك خط المواجهه للخلف
من اماكن مثل اوريخيف وهي بلده تبعد حوالي
خمسه كيلومترات من خطوط المواجهه
انفجارات واعمده دخانا ضغط على المشهد في
ماريوبول الواقعه في دونتسكا والتي تم
استهدافها بصواريخ بعيده المدى اما
المعركه المستميته في باخمه المدمره خفت
وقعها بل انتهت فعليا وفقا نيويورك تايمز
علما بان امال موسكو كانت عريضه في
استثمار الاستيلاء على باخمت كنقطه انطلاق
نحو مدن كبرى في دون باس مثل كرامات
ظروف شبه مثاليه للهجوم المنتظر التربه
الجافه والطقس الملائم لتحرك الدبابات بعض
عوامله يغذيها تلقي كييف لشحنات ضخمه من
الاسلحه وقوات روسيه مرهقه ومشتته
الانتباه بعد قتال مطول في باخموت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات